about ten years ago in front of 5.01
nine million people according to the
Nielsen ratings I had a panic attack on
live television
we're gonna go now to a Dan Harris's at
the news desk
morning Charlie and Diane thank you Wall
Street honors I was doing a job that I'd
done many times before which was filling
in as the newsreader on Good Morning
America that the job basically entails
coming on at the top of each hour and
reading a series of headlines to the
audience bringing them up-to-date on the
news of the day and I was happy and
excited to be there I had no way to
foresee what was about to happen as soon
as the anchors tossed it over to me I
was in the middle of the first story and
I was overtaken by this irresistible
bolt of fear health news now one of the
world's most commonly prescribed
medications may be providing a big bonus
researchers report people who take
cholesterol-lowering drugs called
statins for at least five years may also
lower their risk for cancer my heart
started racing my palms were sweating my
mouth dried up and my lungs seized up
and I was simply unable to breathe you
can see it and hear it on the on the
tape I'm gasping for air it would have
gotten a lot worse it would have become
something like the famous clip from
broadcast News where Albert Brooks
breaks out in flop sweat except for I
did something halfway through my
newscast I'd never done before which is
I quit I gave up I punted I sent it back
to the main hosts of the show lower
their risk for cancer but it's too early
to prescribe statins slowly for a cancer
production that does it for News we're
gonna go back now to Robin and Charlie
what I said was back to you Robin and
Charlie but it was actually Diane Sawyer
and Charlie who were anchoring and I in
my panic was unable to remember that and
you could see they actually in a absurd
little crescendo roll video of Harry
Potter which was the next story I was
supposed to read that the control room
thought I was going to read but I was
unable to do so and in the moments
afterwards I realized that I had had a
panic attack and I was deeply deeply
embarrassed it wasn't until later that I
learned what caused it
I went to see a doctor who was an expert
in panic and he asked me a series of
questions one of which was do do drugs
and I sheepishly said yes I do and he
leaned back in his chair and said
mystery solved the back story is I got
myself into trouble basically because of
a desire to do great at my job which is
something I think a lot of people can
relate to you might call it ambition or
just to drive for for excellence and and
being in love with my job I got to ABC
News when I was 28 years old and if you
look at the pictures I look like I'm
barely post-pubescent and I was working
with these giants like Diane Sawyer and
Peter Jennings and Charlie Gibson and
Ted Koppel and I was keenly aware of how
green I was especially when compared to
these famous people I'd been watching a
television since I was a kid and my way
of coping with that was to become a
workaholic and I threw myself into the
job and after 9/11 I volunteered spent
many years overseas in Iraq and
Afghanistan in the Middle East and when
I came home from that I developed a
depression and I self medicated with
recreational drugs which was a towering
ly stupid move on my part and even
though I wasn't doing it when I was
working
definitely not when I was on the air I
learned from my doctor in his office
after my panic attack that the drugs I
was taking cocaine and ecstasy raised
the level of adrenaline in your brain
and basically guaranteed that I had the
panic attack so that moment in the
doctor's office when he explained to me
what a moron I'd been I knew I had to
make some changes in my life and that
set me off on a strange little unplanned
journey that I talked about in my book
ten percent happier coincidentally at
around the same time my boss at the time
Peter Jennings had assigned me to cover
religion for ABC News a job I didn't
want because I had been raised in a very
secular environment my parents are both
scientists and I tried to tell them I
didn't want to do it and he told me shut
up get you're gonna do it so I ended up
spending many years meeting people of
faith and it really changed my view of
the world and it showed me the value of
having a view of the world that is
larger than your own narrow
self-interest I read a book by self
help guru by the name of Eckhart Tolle
he has sold millions of books I'd never
heard of him a producer recommended I
read the book because she thought maybe
it would be a good story so I read the
book and at first I thought it was
irredeemable garbage nonsense there's a
lot of grandiose language in there and
pseudoscience and over-promising about
how this book is gonna change your life
but then I stumbled upon this diagnosis
of the human condition that I'd never
heard before Eckhart Tolle says we all
have a voice in our head he's not
talking about hearing voices in the
schizophrenic sense he's talking about
our inner narrator the thing that wakes
us up in the morning and Yammer's at us
all day long
it's a unpleasant stew of negative
repetitive ceaselessly self-referential
thoughts constantly judging wanting not
wanting comparing ourselves to other
people casting forward into an imagined
future remembering an idealized past as
opposed to being where you are right now
and I thought yeah that describes me in
fact that voice pretty much is
responsible for all the things that have
most ashamed of in my life including
that panic attack in front of millions
of people and so I was completely
captivated by this description of the
human condition and I went and met
Eckhart Tolle and I found him to be
almost exactly the same in person as he
is on the page which is he's half
incredibly interesting and incisive and
half deeply deeply confusing so
unsatisfied by that encounter I then
went off and met a bunch of other
self-help gurus who also left me
confused many of them left me mildly
infuriated because they were full of a
word that starts with S and ends with T
and my wife at some point after hearing
me Yammer on about Eckhart Tolle and the
like for many many weeks gave me a gift
she gave me a book by a guy named dr.
mark Epstein who's a psychiatrist in New
York City who writes about the overlap
between psychiatry and Buddhism and I
realized when I read this book that all
of the smartest stuff in Eckhart Tolle
book was actually taken pretty much from
the Buddha
and unlike Eckhart Tolle the Buddhists
have some actionable advice for dealing
with the voice in your head problem was
that I didn't want to do it their advice
is to meditate which I always thought
was uniquely ridiculous and only for
people who live in yurts and are really
into aromatherapy and collect crystals
etc etc and wear little symbols on their
hands but in fact as I learned there's
an enormous amount of science that that
says that meditation is simple brain
exercise that can have an extraordinary
impact on your brain in your body it can
lower your blood pressure boost your
immune system and literally rewire key
parts of your brain that have to do with
self-awareness compassion and and stress
so when I heard that I decided to give
it a shot so now I find myself in a
funny position I always thought that
meditation was uniquely ridiculous now
I'm a daily meditator and even worse I'm
a public evangelist for meditation what
I like to say though is it's not gonna
solve all of your problems all those
self-help gurus who tell you that you
can magically cure everything in your
life through the power of positive
thinking
that's baloney it's not gonna happen
it's demonstrably untrue and possibly
even a damaging message to send
however meditation is a scientifically
tested simple thing you can do every day
that will make you significantly happier
I called the book 10% happier for a
couple of reasons one I wanted to
counter program against the
over-promising of the self-help gurus
but also it's I think we're ready for a
more mature realistic dialogue about
happiness and nothing's gonna solve all
of your problems but meditation can
change the relationship between you and
that voice in your head which is
responsible for most of the things
you're probably most embarrassed about
in your life
you